in robotics reinforcement learning
i really loved his lecture notes on
about underactuated robotics one time
i was reading it back and forth and
was even trying to teach from it uh
so it's really awesome to have russ uh
here today
uh talking to us about few challenge
problems from robotics
thank you very much uh yeah i think
many of you heard but i was just saying
it's been an awesome week and my only
regret is that
it's been the first week of classes too
so i'm uh i've been juggling but i
can't wait to go through and fill in all
the things i missed
um and it's my you know pleasure but
also my uh
you know my problem here to give the
last talk of
after everything has been said um so so
i hope i can at least contribute a
unique perspective if not uh
you know say new words but here we go so
um i thought this would be a good you
know following
alex and peter that i would first of all
talk a little bit about
what is working well in robotics and
what's not um
just a little but then start talking
about simulation you know peter talked a
lot about simulation
what role does it play in the work we're
doing in robotics um
the site these ideas of um of policy
search that do connect back to control
like
john was talking about um and some
lessons from parameterizations from
control that i think are
core questions and challenges that
deserve this
group's attention maybe even this
semester that would be amazing
and since we've been talking about
stochastics all day i thought i'd tell
you a little bit about some of our newer
experiments in
the rare event regime um and throughout
and at the end i'll i'll try to make
sure that um i give at least a few of my
sort of recommendations of like
little nugget problems that are you know
are sort of pedagogically valuable i
think for
if you want to study these things in a
robotics context
but to differentiate myself from the
other talks i figured i'd start with a
robot that does a backflip
so um you know this is one of the things
that control is doing very well right so
uh you know i cannot do some of the
things that this robot
is is doing and it's doing it with
you know our our best ideas from modern
control it's solving
you know optimization problems in the
loop and it's doing backflips like
that's amazing
and that's so good um
and even better in slow motion yeah
you know and this is uh this is a model
based you know optimization based
control approach
but keep in mind that this is you know
the up model base does not mean you're
somehow
wed to a super accurate model we have no
model of andres
in the back of the truck jumping up and
down right that is just a disturbance
and the system is robust to it and uh
you know this was one of these late
night videos from
from my cell phone if the audio was on
you'd probably hear you know sleep
deprived giggling or something as we
were doing that
this was right before the big darpa
challenge but these this was an example
of like control
really doing everything it promised
right it just worked incredibly well to
stabilize a very complicated
humanoid robot a 400 pound humanoid
robot
solving optimization problems you know
robot doesn't fall down
but then there are things that you know
i can't do a backflip but there are
things that i can do
and i do all the time that somehow all
of our control tools
seem to fall short right so the one i
put in my abstract when they asked for a
while ago is you know
spreading peanut butter on toast like
that doesn't seem like that should be a
hard
control problem but i i don't know how
to i mean
we've got a lot of good algorithms um
you know but i can't do this one you
know i can't make a robot
spread peanut butter on toast and if you
watch i mean it's actually more nuanced
than you
than you think right there's a lot of
very clever you know force control he's
maybe reasoning a little bit about how
thick the peanut butter is he's
certainly thinking about the edge
there's force control there's pretty
advanced perception
okay so it doesn't seem like that much
of an ask to say you know we'd like
robots that are capable of some of the
basic
human skills but but we actually don't
have it yet
so you know that seems like an
opportunity for rl right
um because if the task is difficult you
know
we don't have maybe the task is
difficult because we don't have a model
right but i think that argument is has
to be made very carefully if you look at
the world of simulation
today you know from computer graphics
from
game engines from um you know this is
just one of my favorite new examples of
someone who's simulating baking okay
like
and and you can score the bread at
different ways at the top and you get
different
uh you know you get all the all the
nuances of like baked bread coming out
you can bake cookies you can
you know don't bet against simulation
right i think to say we don't have a
model
for some of the complex tasks i think
you have to be very very careful about
the way the implications you're making
when you say that
so i thought i would dig in a little bit
first and just think about what does it
mean to have a model and should we be
using them in rl right so what role can
simulation play
if your goal in life is to you know
spread peanut butter have a let's say
have a robot spread peanut butter on
toast
and maybe have a robot you know button a
shirt or there's any number of sort of
household tasks that we would like
robots to be good at
it'd be extremely useful if they were
good at them but they're just out of
scope right now
um you know i think just one of the
the sweeping sort of trends as everybody
jumped back into rl and robotics
um it was very interesting to see like
the first couple years where
people were throwing a lot of the
standard rl algorithms but there was a
pretty
striking shift back towards model based
rl
in the community i remember at the 2018
conference on robot learning where
it was just very clear from the the
abstracts and the talks that
everybody was kind of coming in saying
you know i was i was doing model free
last year but
but i realize now models are going to
help a lot not to say that's the end of
the story but it's just an observation
from my perspective at least of of what
we've seen over the last few years
um and there's and it's it's led to i
don't want to say a crisis but like
there's a there's kind of this
um a conversation that's happening often
about what those models should look like
right and we we have deep learning now
and deep learning does amazing things
and you know often a talk or meeting
will not go by
until somebody asks the question you
know should we be doing
uh deep models or data-driven models
versus physics based models
this was the name of the panel david
data-driven versus physics-based
i didn't actually like the the panel
name and i'll make that distinction in a
second but
um but it's a conversation that's
happening right so and what does that
mean so
here's a some experiments we've been
doing recently in lab
it's a simple relatively simple robot
it's an industrial robotic arm with a
simple gripper
but it's being asked to do tasks that
are outside our comfort zone in terms of
modeling right so
picking up that floppy hat and asking it
to put it accurately on the rack
not only is that maybe hard in a
conventional sense to model in a
simulator but the perception of that
in order to close a feedback loop in
reality it has been traditionally very
very hard for us
um you know flipping up a shoe doesn't
seem like maybe the world's most
important task but
but it's an interesting way we went on
amazon and bought like a hundred
different shoes and trying to
write a single controller that could be
robust to the distribution of possible
shoes
has been actually a really good exercise
and you know plates but plates in like
diverse environments and and trying to
show feedback
so this is the maybe just a kind of um
of problem domain i want to talk about
for a minute here
and like i said there's a big part of
this that is actually a perception
problem
and so i won't dwell much about
perception in the talk but just to tell
you one of the key ideas because you'll
see it a few times here but
this is we do use deep learning in the
front end for perception
almost always now and what you're seeing
in this video is our correspondence
network so the there's just a mouse in
the
still frame here well they're moved
highlighting some
point on a still picture of the hat and
the network is now
outputting the most it's a heat map
saying what does it think the most
similar points on this very different
view of the hat
are and so to find the correspondences
of this visual scene to this visual
scene
is already a hard problem but it's
something we've gotten very good at
training
the networks to do and it becomes a very
useful
front end for our more geometric
thinking about robotics
so for instance here's an approach
that's
maybe you know solve some of the control
problems
we can just do forget about offline
policy optimization if we can
train a deep network model in this case
we try to track a handful of
correspondences we call them key points
in this case but self-supervised key
points
um if we can just build a neural network
model to predict the next step just like
what peter was
talking about a model that says key
points in this location
plus action and controls we're putting
in the actions right and then
predicts the next key points then we can
use that in an online planning process
to try to roll out and make some
decisions
but the problem is with when you when
your model is
maybe trapped inside a deep network
although the prediction of the network
has worked
very well well and we can do it for the
hats and we can do it for all these
complicated things
the model predictive control is still
rookie it's um
most of the people that are using deep
models forward models
for prediction are doing very simple
strategies like
um basically you know random search to
cert i mean cross entropy method kind of
things
in order to do their model predictive
control and surprisingly weak
algorithms for the planning and i think
that's that may be fundamental so let's
let's just be a little um pedantic here
so
when i just uh contrast slightly from
the previous uses of the term here
so when i'm talking about a model i'm
thinking about a stream of inputs a
stream of outputs you know there's not
necessarily a start and an end
we're observing it and we can model it
with initial conditions if that's
of use and you know we have a lot
of models that take a state space form
where we have
you know our state this is what peter
was referring to you know but and we
have our noise and disturbances that
peter
was referring to but we also have you
know parameters that define that model
which might be the physical mass of
something or or the weights of a neural
network
and maybe we have distributions over all
of those things and in this case is my
time right
and why is my outputs i guess i forgot
to label that one
okay but those are not the only types of
models and
i think part of the discussion and the
confusion in the robotics space these
days is about the difference maybe
between state-space models
and the input output models that we i
think many people
in this in this community are also quite
familiar with but
you need not explicitly define a state
of course there's a
for any finite history you can call that
your state vector but but there are
really important classes of models that
are explicit functions of the
recent history of inputs and outputs
don't make any markovian state
assumptions
and you know auto aggressive models are
part of the story too
and i think there's a couple things that
are happening in the
you know physics based versus deep
representations that are happening right
so
most of our physics-based models if you
will the ones based on lagrangian
mechanics
when you turn the crank on the
lagrangian the thing you get out is a
state space model
right also if you're training up a
recurrent neural network
then you're tend to use a state-space
form
but oftentimes when people are
training let's say image plus action to
image type networks
which is commonplace these days in
robotics they're learning
what i would consider to be an auto
regressive model so when people say
um you know the the image is my state
and then they give a
slight history of images i think it's
healthier to think of those as input
output types of models
um and just i mean i think the
connection
you know i think everybody may people
might not like the explicit way i say
this but everybody would agree that a q
function is a form of
a model two right um that's just trying
to predict only one
output and i do think there's lots of
people in robotics that are using q
functions in practice on non-markovian
state representations and
and you know and having good success
okay so um so the i think this
this whole discussion about what are the
right models for
for robotics should they start with
physics or should they start with
um you know should they just be deep
models is really about
the the class of models right where f
and g describe the model class
theta describes the model instance and
when people ask
and they do right deep models versus
physics based models that's really a
question about the model class
you know should we prefer writing f and
g using physics or should we use deep
networks
and to me you know at first blush that
is maybe
not so different than just asking you
know about a representational question
about my network should we be using
reloads or tan non-linearity should we
be using
uh you know lstms or transformer
networks or whatever that's just an
architecture question
but i really dislike the the when people
say things like it's kind of a pet peeve
like
is it data driven or physics based and
it's like
hold on every physics you know when we
say physics based we're still going to
use data
right that don't don't say that that
we've somehow given up on learning or
data or whatever right i mean i
i think the the the best data scientists
we've had maybe are the the physicists
right that
have come up with very simple models uh
fit to extreme
i mean think about the noisy data that
they were getting back in the day right
um and somehow they were able to give us
this incredibly rich
pyramid class of parametric models that
we can now fit to data and we do i mean
we do system identification on
physics-based models every time we use
them
in robotics right so it's not about data
versus physics
and i don't know this is this is a
little cheeky but i i feel like when
i i've been saying it with my students
and it helps me it helps me like somehow
sleep at night but
you know what if what if newton had had
deep learning right
then you know and and the
uh the output was you know here's the
weights and the architecture of my deep
network
i think we'd be in a pretty different
place in the world right so
um i think there's huge value that must
be appreciated about being able to fit a
complex model to data that is predictive
but i still long for more and more
parsimonious models
and and i i i will be a little bit of a
call here in this talk
of trying to keep finding those
parsimonious
simple models um that we can do better
planning with
in robotics so you know when i go and
think about the
lagrangian or newtonian or whatever
perspective of a problem like this then
you know suddenly if i'm thinking about
the state space of the problem then
there's a you know there's a natural
answer right it's there every one of
those
pieces has a um has a pose
you know it's represented in some 3d se3
it's got a spatial velocity but then you
know the number of states is changing
every time this happens so it's a hybrid
system and
and somehow you know writing the state
estimator doesn't seem like a good task
right
how do i estimate the pose of the piece
of the onion that's somehow in the
middle of the pile there
and so when you start thinking about
these questions about what are the right
models for robotics i think
um the physics based models are falling
down not
because they're not accurate not because
they can't describe the data or even
hard to calibrate to the data
there's other reasons about
observability and the like so
what makes a model useful um
and i think there's different use cases
and we're seeing that in a big way
in the reinforcement learning world
right so um simulation
is kind of one use case and the monte
carlo policy evaluation and the off
policy optimization
um that's a use case where i think
having
expensive potentially hard to to
reason about models but that can act
like a black box can be very useful
as long as they are you know predictive
in the sense that
things you get out of your simulator are
you know resemble the things you get out
of the real world
you'd really like them to also have some
notion of coverage right somehow the
things that happen in the real world
also can be come out of your simulator
you'd love it although it's not clear if
we need it right because of important
sampling and other things right but you
would love to have somehow the
distribution of simulations match the
distribution you get in the real world
and there is some sense of course where
all that
requires reliable system identification
which arguably we've been doing better
at with deep models than some of our
physics models but there's
incredibly strong results of course in
some of the model based
system id and there's a bunch of other
things that you might
might make a model better or worse
whether it's generalizable efficient
repeatable interpretable
but i think this online decision making
and the you know
the regret and the the online
optimization you know these kind of
these kind of questions i think they
really do force a different
class of models right so of course you'd
like them to be reasonable and accurate
and generalizable but somehow i think
efficiency starts coming in in a much
more dramatic way
if i can't do planning on it with any
reasonable algorithm then
it's it's not as useful to me and if i
have a state space model
that is not observable then it's very
very hard to use in reality
um and then you know a lot of times our
models are trained on too much
right if i'm trying to button my shirt
and somehow the step
one is to estimate the entire state of
my shirt then then that somehow
feels like i've estimated more than i
needed to and maybe wasted
time resources or even accuracy on it
and i think part of the confusion about
how well deep networks are working
compared to
you know physics models are working it
actually more comes down to the
observability question right state space
models
they tend to be more efficient and
compact but they require state
estimation
and you know the the prospect of state
estimation like i said when you're
chopping onions
is not is not does not make me
optimistic right
and again the lagrangian state is not
necessarily the task
relevant state and i think maybe the
bigger thing that's happening
in the neural network world is really
that we're building i o models
and that relieves us of the problems of
state estimation but it does
potentially compromise some of our
algorithms
um by the way i think uh that if we
wanted to go to more i o models that
doesn't mean we have to throw away
mechanics that's an interesting
you know path forward i think
but then just to finish this sort of um
point about the models right i think
there is at least maybe one way where
the physics-based models
are sort of somehow fundamentally
different than
deep models or any universal
approximators
and that's about taking a stand on what
won't happen i mean physics models are
sort of not
universal and that's great because
somebody went out and took a stand
and said there are constraints there are
some things that will never happen right
there's conservation of mass there's
conservation of energy there's maximum
dissipation there's all these
important um rules that are constraints
and arguably these constraints give our
models their structure
right and and and it it's possible you
know i think
uh because the rl problem is so
general it it has been harder to see the
same kind of structured optimization
results that we see on more structured
models in my
manipulator equations i can exploit the
positive definiteness of the mass matrix
and the branch induced sparsity and
and and all these different things and
we know it's control affine
and um i wonder if there's a fundamental
tension there
about universal approximation and and
not having you know maybe
without any structure we won't ever be
able to do anything more than
sgd okay so that's
a quick rant about models but you know i
think the
failings of our physics based models are
actually more due
to the unreasonable burden of estimating
the what i'll call the lagrangian state
and parameters they are it's not that
physics is wrong it's that
it's often coming in too detailed and
we are able to fit deep models for a lot
of these problems that i've been
thinking about and caring about about
you know laundry and food and the like
um but they still
fail me because i can't plan or do
control design even offline with them
very reliably i'm missing my strongest
algorithms
um so i want you know the next newton to
come around and have
him or her work on onions laundry and
peanut butter i guess
okay so here's another question or
challenge
that i that i would love this community
to to work on
which i think is is already on people's
mind but you know
why when what rates does gradient-based
policy search work and just to add
a little bit to that conversation from
the robotics perspective here
right people are using um policy
gradient
and sometimes getting surprising
surprising results right like
um i mean there was a lot of compute
behind this but even with all that
compute
i wouldn't have a priori said yes it's
going to find a good policy
right and and i think that's a
very very interesting and important
question about understanding the cases
when
policy search is going to find a good
policy a gradient-based policy search is
going to find a good policy and when it
will not
right and some of the there's a great
community but
i think most of you well many of you
might have known but about this l4 dc
community
this learning for dynamics and control
is a new conference
that is bringing together some of the
controls community with the
the learning community and i'm super
excited about the prospect of those of
these groups getting together
you know some of the types of results
that are getting discussed in that world
are
great they're they're talking about um
convergence
of policy gradient methods on
you know well-understood traditional
control problems like the linear
quadratic regulator so it was very
interesting
to basically hear a result from miriam
who who's base
who says you can actually do the naive
thing
which is just a search over the feedback
gains we call them k
always in lqr directly with policy
gradient
we knew before she gave her talk that
that
that the objective was not uh convex in
that constraint
but she showed that it was still it
would still find a global optima
and you know mahalo has been doing more
really nice work giving some bounds on
on how quickly you can
you can find those um this is a great um
you know trend i think if we can grow
the sort of
sample complexity you know understanding
into more and more of these control
problems i think it's really good
but what one of the things that was
really interesting as these results
started coming out
um there were some people that were like
that's amazing i i didn't expect that
and
and there were a few of the you know the
control theorists were like
yeah i mean of course right and
and i've been trying to you know get
those people to
to articulate in a rigorous way this
this understanding that they had
uh and why it was somehow obvious to
them if not for
for the for the rest of us i guess i
went out of order in my slides
and it comes down to the fact that there
are convex parameterizations
through a change of coordinates uh for
these problems
and i'll say something in a slide or two
and just even the existence of those
convex parameterizations which are sort
of
a smooth transformation away you know
there's a topological argument which
says
basically if there's a convex
parameterization that lives over
over here then there should be a you
know you can't lose your
uh you can't introduce new local minima
through that transformation
so um you know if i make any
contribution to that it'll be getting
getting those folks to write it down
carefully but i think it's a super
exciting
trend but there are there's also a
reason to think that stuff shouldn't
work like you shouldn't just be able to
um to search over feedback gains and
expect
global optimization to work you know
global results and so here's the
simplest example
um that i like so this is now instead of
state feedback the reason it's not
a counter example of the rev previous
problem
the lqr result is about if you had u
equals negative kx
okay but it's different if you have u
equals negative ky
and you have an output system here so
now you're doing
output feedback and this is static
output feedback okay
and this is a particular one where
you've got your feedback parameterized
by a scalar
k and the reason i say it's a claim it's
a counter example is because
the set of stabilizing k is actually a
disconnected set
right so i can give you 1k in fact i
wrote a couple down here i can give you
1k
you know 0.9 if you started there um you
know
there's another k in between there and
where you want to be
that is unstable just flat out you know
unstable so so independent of the
objective
basically essentially independent of the
objective
uh uh you know this is not going to be
good for gradient descent
so it's super interesting to think about
um you know
is somehow the the open ai hand or dota
2 or or all these examples how is you
know
is there some reason why that they they
actually worked
okay so what characterizes the good
cases
right so maybe it's the over
parameterization of the deep policies
right but and i would not be surprised
if there's some comparable story to the
interpolating solutions in high
dimensional policy space now you know
that we're understanding better for
supervised learning
but i don't have it yet and maybe
someone here does but but i i don't have
that
yet i don't understand how um
deep over parameterization is enough to
give me
convergence to a good policy
but maybe it could it could be other
things right so i think control has
traditionally studied algorithms
uh you know even when it's not about
worst-case results
somehow there's just even inherent in
the problem statement
is this idea that you know this
controller must work for all possible a
b and c even if there's no like robust
control analysis even in
the nominal case and that's very hard
you know maybe the world never i mean
that could means that can mean systems
linear systems that have poles and zeros
interleaved in some like
evil way right and and maybe those just
don't happen in the real world and maybe
if we're doing um you know more targeted
policy search on
on distributions of problems that are
generated from physics simulators
maybe something something how better or
maybe even adding the stoke
of course you know adding stochasticity
can potentially smooth out the landscape
but maybe it's actually
making the landscape fundamentally
better so so i don't know is it the
distribution of tasks is it the over
parameterization is it both
but i really like to know i'd like to
have confidence if i had a new problem
do i think policy search is going to
work for that gradient-based policies
which is going to work for this or not
i think there are other like important
lessons from control for instance
um from better better controller
parameterizations and i started talking
about this a little bit so
you know just because you can search
over u equals negative kx
and find up find the the best k
it doesn't mean you should right so if
you start doing these convergence
analysis
then um then you're going to i think be
unhappy with
the rate of convergence right and it's
part it also is related to this idea
that the set of stabilizing k
is non-trivial you have to be
potentially careful to not walk out into
an unstable model
okay just as a simple example
you know if you if you do have a model
then it could be better
if in an lqr problem where your cost is
parameterized by matrices q and r
um you why not search over q and r
because then for every positive
now the the constraints are trivial for
every positive q and
positive you know positive semi-definite
q and positive definite r
i get a stabilizing k out so maybe
that's a better thing to search for this
is something we actually looked at a
while ago
and it does bear out in simple
experiments uh you know that searching
in q r is better but
there are other parameterizations that
are well known in the controls
literature that are even better still
than that um so for instance you know
for lqg
h infinity and some of these other
linear
type optimizations we know convex
parameterizations like the eula
parameterization is another one we
looked at
um in the in the paper uh which is a
form of disturbance based feedback
and that and for the linear problems
actually convexifies
uh the parameter space so i think it
should be a much better landscape and it
it seemed experimentally to be so of
course we have you know euler's
uh in the time domain is is got some
limits there are
lmi formulations of lqr for instance
that
use different would suggest natural um
you know re-parametration
parameterizations of the problem that
could potentially help learning rates
significantly
right um you know the result of those
ideas
uh is feels restricted to linear systems
if your goal is to get convexity out but
my guess is that actually if you just
care about convergence rates
um you know somehow regularizing the
problem
um you know getting rid of bad
conditioning and the like
i think that those benefits are probably
those lessons are probably much more
general
so here's the eula parameters just in
the simplest possible case
of the eula parameters that i thought i
could put up in case people haven't seen
it
so this is uh my standard lqr problem uh
at the top okay normally this is an ex
this is an
over you know in finite time problems
we can express the the feedback law as a
time varying function k of of n okay so
in general i might have to search over
a different k for a different x if i
have a finite that's just like your
finite
dynamic programming right but if you
think about the
and this is the standard um way we write
down our
rk our feedback law but the problem with
that is of course that if you
if you start taking it through the
dynamics then you get k's multiplied by
k's get them multiplied by k's you get a
you know some non-convex combination of
k's so your decision variables are
highly non-convex
the your objective is highly non-convex
and your decision variables
so the euler parameters in the case
where there's no noise is actually
trivial you just say i can express
exactly the same policies
by just parameterizing everything off of
x0
okay that sounds a little silly but i'm
going to say u at time
4 is still just multiplied by x 0. if
there's no noise i can just roll my
model forward i know what x n would have
been
and that gives me now only an additive
you know a linear dependence on
the parameters in my rollouts okay and
then if you do want to if you do have
disturbances then you do
disturbance-based feedback so you still
parameterize u as a function of only x
zero
but then you can additionally add in
coefficients times the noise which you
can actually infer back in a causal way
okay and so
this is just a way for finite time
problems or for in the frequency domain
it has
it's mostly presented in the frequency
domain um you know it's a way to make
your problem convex and this should be a
better parameterization
even if you're doing uh stochastic
gradient descent
um and you know that's that's maybe what
the the linear control tells us
but but i also think there's lessons to
be had from
um from the roboticists and you know i
mean like the domain experts we i call
them the robot whisperers i
i was talking to stephen boyd the other
day and he says oh you mean bob
every field has like a bob which is like
the domain experts that just know
that always have the right answer and
maybe can't explain why it's the right
answer but there's always somebody in
the back room that sort of
you know completely understands the
problem right and um
you know i know a bunch of them right
this is andy is actually the person in
this video from boston dynamics who
who wrote the controller that makes the
robot open the door
and it's like super ridiculously robust
right and there's no learning there
that's that's a
hand engineered controller that andy had
enough domain knowledge
to think through all the possible things
that somebody could do
to make that robot you know struggle to
open the door and you know the door
almost always gets opened and the robot
always gets through even when he starts
abusing it okay um
and it actually there's a longer history
too and this is one of the ones i would
say is a good
canonical problem for people if they're
interested in like a toy robotics
problem
so this is actually um this is the 2d
hopper i know there's a
hopper in open ai gym that's the you
know
with the foot on the ground this is this
is the real i guess hopper
um from the mit leg lab in in the 80s
uh it's it's a beautiful example and it
actually evolved into the
all the quadrupeds and the like that you
you see from boston dynamics today
but the thing that was amazing about it
was the intuition
and the simplicity of the controller
right so this was
at a time when the robots were moving
very slowly this robot started throwing
itself through the air
but the amazing thing is that the
control description
like the book there's a nice 200 page
book or whatever but
the controller description fit on a
single page i mean this was the
diagram at the top of the page and there
were a couple like pde controllers
right below it on the page and um
and that's not i mean that's not unique
to this this is the way people
write controllers for practical robotics
they tend to have little state machines
they're guarded on some you know simple
events
reach down until you touch you know pull
until you feel this if you feel
something crazy
transition and you know
there's it's always annoyed me that
despite all the optimization you give me
a perfect model
i don't know how to write an objective
or solve an optimization problem that
would give me a controller that is
better than
it is in some sense more robust than the
one that was written on a single page
um there's so much baked in intuition
about
the what works on real robots um that
that it's very hard to beat and i think
it's a standing challenge for us
in let's say optimization based control
okay so since i knew we were talking
about rare events and
today um you know i'm i'm not an expert
in it but i've been thinking about it
more and more because i think the
problem domain needs that type of
thinking and so
i thought i would uh i would you know
show us show you some of our experiments
with it and are getting me getting my
head around it
um work with some really good students
who are experts in it
uh so but let me tell you that in the
form of a story right so
uh we're getting to the point where for
some tasks robots
actually fail rarely and the learning
that we want to do
is really in the corner cases so here's
an example that we've been
working on at toyota research it's about
loading the dishwasher
so that's siwon he is one of our robot
whisperers by the way
um you know he dumps stuff in the in the
sink
and then we let the robot go and
actually the robot goes kind of all day
long
well pre-covered it went all day long
every day you know and
its job is to load the dishwasher and uh
you know it throws the refuge
refuse in the pile on the the right and
it puts the mugs in the top shelf it
puts the
plates in the bottom shelf it puts the
silverware in the silverware
rack at the top and it's really
complex but it's really pretty robust it
fails
the whole task fails very rarely even
though some individual components will
fail it's got layers of robustness that
make it
you know get the task done almost always
and it's really taken us to this point
of trying to understand
how do you to make a system like that
it's not it's still not good enough it
fails regularly enough that you don't
want it in your kitchen
right but it's empirically very hard to
find
um to find the corner cases which cause
a good policy to be differentiated from
a
not quite good enough policy right so we
do have simulation for this we've made a
huge
investment in simulation and we simulate
the thing all the time and we can run
lots more simulations than we can
possibly run
hardware experiments but still it's not
enough partly partly because
we don't know the right distribution of
simulations to run
and we lack some of the really
fundamental
tools of trying to take rare events in
reality and bring them back into
simulation you know those are the hard
parts is calibrating
distributions of simulations when it
when the lighting conditions matter the
shape of the mug matters the
friction properties matter you know
those inverse graphics problems are
pretty tough um but we really are in
this
regime of subtle bugs like
um we finally after watching the robot
for a while we
we saw it start failing very rarely but
in this
this this funny way where the robot
would pick up a mug
start going to put it down and then set
it then like
decide it couldn't set it down so it
would set the mug back down on the
counter
and it got in like this infinite loop
and and it turned out that the reason
was that there was some perceptual noise
in the estimator of where our dish rack
was and there was a
like diabolical position that the dish
rack could get itself
in where with very high probability
the robot when it looked when it was
picking up the mug said yeah the dish
this rack is open started moving but
with very high probability before it
finished setting down the mug
there was at least one sample which said
nope that dish rack is too far in and we
had you know too fragile of a threshold
in the middle of our
huge complicated algorithm and so the
robot would you know set the mug back
down and then just get in this infinite
loop
and that was very very hard to find but
we found it eventually in simulation
and then we found we saw it on reality
uh weeks later but
so now we make simulations look like
this right this is our important
sampling right this is like
um the poor robot is tortured because
the dish racks are just moving like
crazy all the time in every simulation
because we want to excite those
those corner cases okay but that this
was a
human tuned uh important sampling
strategy and how do we do better
right um i've been working with matt
o'kelly and
monsina and john duchy and a few others
on on trying to understand how you would
do rare event simulation for
that class of problems that has you know
all the complexity of a
deep neural network perception system
and a complex physics model and
everything and uh you know these guys
have made some really
uh exciting progress so um
you know and one of the couple key ideas
that i'll just communicate quickly but
one of them is
changing from falsification to
estimating the failure of probability
and they're using tools from adaptive
multi-level splitting and hamiltonian
monte carlo and and doing some
neat new tricks with normalizing flows
in order to do some parametric warping
of the distributions of our sampling
distributions and i'll show you
sort of quickly what that looks like so
you know one of the problems with our
traditional my traditional let's say
formulation of just trying to find any
counter example any failure case
is that you tend to find the same type
of failure case over and over again
okay and the you know fundamentally if
we just say this is a failure
you know run your simulator find
failures you you tend to not get
coverage in the way you'd want to so if
there's
you know a pretty non-convex landscape
or whatever there's really no incentive
for my falsification algorithm
to find different failure cases on each
time
if we change ma our our question from
you know what's the general form of the
question where you would get some
diversity
we've been pretty happy with this much
harder problem of trying to estimate the
failure probability right if i say
what's the probability of that function
um being less than 20
then in order to get that probability
right it has to somehow visit
all of those um those states right and
of course it's a harder
problem so um we've been working with
the risk-based framework now
right where we're trying to do important
sampling uh by
you know prioritizing the the heavy part
of the
distribution that we care about in the
failure region
and learning samplers the in these you
know in these warping functions
in normalizing flows in order to learn
samplers that
that work in this regime will pull from
those regimes
and in the toy problems they look you
know
intuitively exactly what i'd like i take
a a simple problem of
of sampling from the unit covariance um
normal distribution and having a rare
event of just trying to get a sample
that was greater than six and
okay and and
that's you know extremely low
probability and we get these
you know these monte carlo approaches to
build a ladder
of samplers that will eventually um
sample very frequently in that domain
and give us
better estimates of the probability of
failure with asymptotic bounds i like
that conversation
but the cool thing is they've been able
to find
super complicated failure cases in
really
full-on models so so they're the best
example from matt and amand so far has
been
um in my opinion is this uh they put the
full
comma dot ai open pilot um
you know autopilot basically into a full
simulator this carla simulator and
started
sampling over really diverse lighting
conditions and other things
and let me just play that again so so
what's happening here is they caught a
failure case
where i kid you not the sun
gives a flare off the back of the
windshield of the previous car
and it causes a crash okay and uh you
know
the cool thing is if you look at the
open pilot
output um it actually
knows that it's uncertain about the the
location of the previous car
but the controller did not change course
and ended up still making a mistake
so you know these are i'm excited about
these algorithms
um not just because um
they're finding some corner cases but
because i think more fundamentally
it feels like the the right kind of spec
that could scale to the complexity of
problems we've been asking in robotics
and
and autonomous driving these days right
so
um super high dimensional black box
models
empirical risk estimation i was
skeptical that we'd be able to make any
progress there
i am excited about what i'm seeing so
far
um right so and i really think
you know asking for a autonomous car
that can never crash
is is um probably not the right
formulation asking for a robot that will
never break a dish is probably not the
right formulation
but what i think we should be aiming to
do is these risk empirical risk
estimations and and
the connections to rl are just waiting
to happen i think and and
let's see if they can play out okay so
i'll just end with a couple you know
specific problem instances that distill
some of these kind of problems down to
things that are
you know ai open ai kind of benchmarks i
mentioned one the hopping robot is a
great example i i've considered it a
standing challenge for
a decade in under actuated robotics
right that that
that none of our optimization algorithms
can do as well as mark reaper's one page
controller
the dishwashing gave us a couple other
really good benchmarks okay so
there's a subtle controller written
by a robot whisperer c1 that picks up
plates
even when there's stacks of plates and
even when the sink is cluttered and
everything like this
and it works really really well um but
and we've been trying to replace it with
a learned policy
and we haven't got a learned policy that
will outperform
c1's hand design controller yet we're
banging on it and i think i
actually think we might do it but um
the it's really it's connected to this
this rare event kind of idea is
i mean the many examples of picking up
the dish are actually pretty easy but
every once in a while there's a really
hard one
and somehow siwon had all these
you know all these things in his head
when he wrote that controller and he
guarded against them beautifully and
and i can't get the algorithms to do it
yet andres has been
has been working on this along with a
few other um super strong people at
toyota research and um you know we've
got it down to
what i consider to be a textbook problem
um with very simple
we have even simpler models than this
with like point fingers and
distributions over plates that i can
write down as a palmdp and actually
solve
uh you know but then you start running
into the limits of your
model this one is doing policy gradient
on a you know fairly simple
model uh it's fun to watch the all the
standard outtakes you get when you're
doing rl the first thing we asked was
just that the plate gets to a certain
angle and it
manages to go and you know flip the
plate up in the air and you know all the
all the good stuff but uh this is what
i'm actually putting into my new notes
my
my manipulation notes as i i think it
deserves to be a
sort of textbook example for
multi-contact control
and we are hammering on this with not
only all the different methods from
policy search to palm dps and everything
in between
but we're also trying to attack it with
our with rich distributions over
possible
tasks so distributions of plates of mugs
we have procedural mug generators that
have a small number of parameters that
generate a diversity of mugs that
capture what we see
we have parameterized lighting
conditions you name it
okay so um there's also i think we need
something that's kind of a
simple textbook example for the kind of
problems that we saw open ai
deal with um and we have one that i like
now
in this uh we call it our planar gripper
rick and hunkai have been working on
this
also i think it's ready to be a textbook
example and
there's a few other people that have
things that sort of look like this we
actually have hardware that looks like
this
too but this is kind of boiling it down
to the plane to its essentials it's
still a very rich multi-contact problem
but it's something that i think we can
hammer on and really understand
and all of those are so i have a new set
of notes and for manipulation now
as of this fall well they're being
written uh
you know in real time but uh
one of the things that kovid did for me
well i
i don't know if i would have done it
anyways but i i spent my summer trying
to make it sure make sure i could teach
class remotely really well
and uh for those of you that did
download slides.com you're actually
running a live
3d uh render of that of that you can all
twitter it yourself and i got it now so
that
our robot simulators our high-end robot
simulators can run in anybody's browser
with zero install so um
in fact after we're all done here um
if anybody wants i could get them
running a robot in
less than five minutes so um okay how
well is control working in robotics
today
we talked a little bit about it
backflips yes
peanut butter no right okay so um
i think simulation has a really
important role to play but it's still
hard
and it's it's interesting to watch
people
struggling with physics-based versus
deep models
i think there are some great questions
in gradient-based policy search
great questions about the intersection
of control and rl
at in the parameterization level super
interesting things to do with the rare
event regime
overall i'm just overwhelmingly excited
that the theorists are coming
and to help me with my problems i hope
please please so um
so we have good challenging problem
instances i named a few of them
um onions and shoelaces we have some
canonical versions of those too i didn't
think they'd fit but um if you are
interested in this kind of stuff
i am sincerely interested in bringing
more theoretical understanding into
these problems
so drop me a note i'll end there but
i'll say that if you
um if you do actually want to run a
robot
right now with no install then this is
what you would do
um you can actually in your browser
right now this is a live link and
anybody who used slides.com
you can just click on that button and
click the first cell and that will
install the machine on google cloud for
you and i will talk you through it after
any questions are done
if you didn't use slides.com you can
just go to that website
go to chapter one and click on open in
co-ed
okay i'll stop and take any questions
very cool thank you
um yeah very intriguing uh
so do you have one question that i was
saving to the end
it's from aaron snoswell
uh says hey drake question about physics
data models
uh recently the machine learning reading
group at my university has covered
a lot of papers on deep coupon operator
theory
learning good latent linear
approximations for complex dynamics from
data
love to hear your thoughts on this sort
of approach to the simulation problem
awesome yeah so i mean coupon operators
are a cool idea everything's linear if
you're high enough dimensional
uh you know and that's um and it's
connected to occupation measures and
other things we know from control
um the question is just how high
dimensional do you have to get before
things get meaningfully
linear and um i think
for contact type problems it's pretty
daunting
uh so i go i will completely admit you
know every
there's probably some six or twelve
month cycle where i'm like oh we should
try that again but
but uh i'm not in one of those cycles
right now
i guess i've seen uh a talk from you
just half a year ago when you were still
in that cycle or like you were coming
out of it
maybe occupation measure yeah there's
good stuff there but it's on your
cutting stuff yes i remember occupation
measures they're showing up
uh yeah cool lots of lots of good stuff
here
so i have a foundational question so
do you think that like so we are we
in audio theory tend to to think about
you know
the the argument meek problems like how
to design other algorithms and like
different uh classes of problems
not so much right so like we we put up
put on our machine learning hat and we
try to be
model agnostic right so we are kind of
inheriting that
from the whole field of machine learning
is this you're also
asking about simple complexity and the
like and right and wouldn't you expect
that there's classes of problems that
you would get much
even if you have a generic algorithm i'm
okay with i i i
also have a slight preference for
algorithms that are not too
wet to any one problem but
wouldn't it be great if you could
understand that those algorithms
work super efficiently in some classes
of problems and especially if the real
world
dished up those problems often no i
actually wanted to ask you whether this
is
this is uh something this is a mistake
or not
or we should be you know like should you
take
a model first approach think about the
classes of systems
that you need to control and then think
about
what type of you know algorithms you
should be using for this type of uh
systems
rather than taking a holy generic
approach that
okay it's it's great because in general
it could be applicable to many things
but
maybe overall it's going to be just too
weak
i think so i think we're there i mean i
think we're seeing that right i think
the fact the fact that
you know we can write a policy grading
algorithm for any problem is cool but
but it's not going to converge for every
problem
right there's a there was a trivial
counter example in the talk but
so the fact that we're seeing people use
it effectively and
getting convergence means there's
something deeper to understand about
even the simple policy gradient
algorithms i think right is that
you know there is some class of problems
where people okay
you're flipping the question there
you're saying that okay you have this
argument
and it seems to work well what is the
class of problems for which this works
well
let's understand that right you're right
that the other side is
super interesting in fact i'm i'm maybe
more interested in the other side which
is that
you should be able to make more powerful
algorithms if you restrict the class of
problems right and that's
i guess what control what robotics has
been doing more traditionally right so
i've written i've taken as my class of
models the manipulator equations
right that have certain structure and
we've written much stronger algorithms
because we've restricted ourselves to
that
it doesn't feel very restrictive but
it's a class that's much
much smaller than all x dot equals f of
x right
um and i think you kind of need that
in order to write stronger algorithms
that's kind of funny that you're saying
that because uh
on some previous slide you had you had
this slide about
uh the potential challenges that come
from language and state
right and all like every time you write
these models like we are just so
inherently strongly relying on that
concept
and then if you have a perception action
loop
then that state estimation problem
maybe just killing everything like all
the advantage that could come from them
but i guess
that's the tension like how do you like
do both
at the same time i i have a hope i i
think we are
if you use the naive generalized
coordinates from lagrangian
and write that i have a class of models
i can work with but they're not useful
in the state estimation sense
i have to believe that there are other
models that are not arbitrary there's
another class of models we haven't found
yet that
where somehow my single onion turns into
a pile of onions because i
you know i don't think about every onion
anymore there's something that happens
you know
that somehow i'm starting to think about
it as a pile except for when that one
little piece gets close to the edge of
the cutting board and i have to pull it
back and suddenly i attend to that and
you know there's all these ideas are
still there but
how do you write a class of models that
is not arbitrary
is not universal it has structure that's
exploitable
um but it's it works in this intuitive
physics space
that's the that's the question i mean i
think very simple models
can solve those problems i just think we
haven't spent enough time
trying to find them
yeah i think so like do you have
parametrization or
uh anything like that where you have
something in between the the very strong
uh mother-based approach
uh which very strongly relies on the
structure of the models and like
something that's a little bit less
on the parametric side i don't know so
so okay
the linear models seem not rich enough
for pushing carrots around
or onions around right but maybe
piecewise affine models are
like we know pretty well how to do that
um they're hard to fit they're you know
combinatorially bad
to fit optimally but you know that's a
class of models that i can write
strong algorithms against and i can
think about you know approximate
planning solutions and all these other
things um maybe that's good enough maybe
that's still
kind of too specific because probably i
only you know i don't need to
have a detailed uh prediction of
of i mean first what's the state in that
piecewise affine model but if i could
come up with like from
the key points or something one of these
representations we've been playing with
from perception
and fit you know whether it's it's a lo
i don't i don't
want to be low dimensional i think
that's the wrong notion of some simple
but something that i can
efficiently reason about so maybe it's a
small number of pieces in a piecewise a
fine system or maybe it's
you know there's some other metric of of
um you know and how do what's that right
model class
right f equals m a was a pretty good one
but but you know and so and maybe it's
maybe it is still f equals m
a but but not a being the generalized
coordinates
yeah i guess that completely misses out
on the perception aspect and
that's the challenge right um
you can get intermediate representations
out of perception that you could learn
simple models on i don't want i don't
want my resnet
in the simple model that's not simple
right but
but maybe i can use a perception front
end and predict uh
you know relevant strong features
that come out of a perception system and
how they move forward in time and that's
the kind of models we've been thinking
about
okay but you're definitely saying that
if you want to make progress on these
challenging instances we should
specialize the arguments
in some way it's not going to to fly if
we just like stay at the level of
oh actor critic oh police agreement oh
value-based method
deep q learning whatever right i i don't
fault people who are studying that
but i'm i'm likely to be the one
there's a little there's a lot of good
people thinking about those i'm going to
try to think about the structured models
that's my that's my personal preference
okay interesting
that's your bat yeah someone
yeah someone was saying that you should
you should also name your steak
if you're betting
anyways um maybe we can play that out of
life
um okay um
kid
if anybody wants to and they've clicked
far enough through in that simulation oh
yeah like i
i posted this in discord uh so
people could try that
it's a jupiter notebook with three cells
that you
if you ran the first one it takes two
minutes to provision the cloud machine
you run the second one you will get a
simulation of a robot arm that you can
now drive around and try to move a red
brick around
and that's just like i think aaron was
actually already doing that
cool so i i'm excited about you know
i think some of our most advanced um
robot simulators can be pretty
accessible now uh
so i'm teaching that course online if
anybody wants to follow along it's it's
pretty open so yeah
all right so one more question uh quick
thoughts on the state of
training pre-training in simulation
how far are we from solving the
challenges without the extensive hand
tuning of the simulated environments i
was always thinking about this
so-called seem to real question yeah
yeah so what do you think
um okay so i think again there's lessons
from robust control
so um there's a notion of i think
if you have lots of control authority
then your model can be very sloppy
and you can expect cinderella to work
because you can just overpower the
uncertainty and the like you can get
you can ask it to be robust to anything
and to some extent
a lot of the sim derail work we've seen
the fact that people are putting like
cheetah patterns and checkerboards and
whatever all over and they're training
their perception systems against that
and they're changing friction properties
between like zero and
ten i mean that's coefficients of
friction of zero shouldn't be good right
but
you know and somehow they're still
getting something to work that means the
problems we're solving in a control
sense are pretty
easy i think when you start trying to do
more complex
tasks that are more at the limits of
performance
then you're going to need to get tighter
models in order to have those transfer
right if you ask yourself to be rob if
you're like the millennium falcon trying
to
get you know as the doors of the death
star are closing and you're gonna you
then you gotta have a pretty good model
for that otherwise
um robust control is gonna say no i
can't do that i can't give you a
certificate that for all
possible death stars you know it's
always going to work so
um the question is you know where i
think there's tons of interesting
problems in robotics and manipulation
for instance where
they're actually pretty easy and the
simulators don't have to be that
accurate
but it's also been interesting i mean
even like two years ago my students
would have said
you can't do manipulation research and
simulation it doesn't work well enough
the perception you know the
simulating a camera is too hard and
simulating contact is too hard
too difficult let's say but um uh that's
changed in the last two years and i
i'm very optimistic about how far it
will go
interesting isn't there a challenge
in in uh figuring out what parameters of
the simulator to change and
what to shake what rattle to what extent
and like eventually i have the feeling
that if you try everything that is
another combinatory explosion that
you're facing so maybe you should be a
little bit more smart about
how you're doing this yeah yeah
there's also i mean for for the you know
the general rl theory community i think
there's a
there's interesting questions about how
accurate your distributions over
parameters need to be right do we
do we need to have um the probability of
a simulation to being right or do you
just need to have coverage
right because maybe you actually um
in an important sampling sense you
actually want to have the rare events
happen more often right
so if i just am i just fitting uniform
distributions to every parameter and
that's good enough or do i have to
tune in something with really high
fidelity um i think we don't know what
the demands are
from the synthesis algorithms yet
but i am yeah and we're we are you're
seeing starting to see people in
robotics at least i'm sure other domains
are doing it too
trying to fit you know probabilistic
models to more and more complicated
situations where
you're trying to get not only just
somehow some maximum likelihood estimate
out but you're trying to fit the
distributions
we're trying to get distributions over
our certainty of the mugs and have
probability fly all the way through the
system
so um yeah we'll see it's it it's not
easy
lots of data so that's the one thing is
i think robotics is about to be you know
the type of robotics i'm talking about
of home robots and the like
it feels like we're finally going to get
to be one of those fields that has big
data
you know it's it's getting close because
yeah and we're gonna have robots right
um yeah a different question
um so in reinforcement learning we
traditionally formulate reinforcement
learning is a single objective
optimization problem
uh a recent pet peeve of mine is to
just to get people's uh opinion about
like how limiting is that
uh i think that we should stick to the
single reward objective or should we
expand how
important is that if i had to place my
chips wherever i
would give you a stakes or whatever i
think
that trying to solve every problem is
too hard
trying to solve a single problem you
know single objective is too narrow
i would put my chips on trying to solve
a distribution of tasks or distribution
of problems right
if you get one controller one control
parameterization that can solve
some family of problems then maybe you
get some some of the benefits of
of being problem specific but and even
possibly some of the benefits that would
come from not being too problem specific
but i mean certainly i was not super
clear
i i was more thinking about you know
like you'd have multi objective
optimization
instead of a single reward function i
don't know whether that was clear
you know like in a robot like uh how do
you like what's your reward function
when you want you you mentioned that
when you first ran the experiment the
plate was just flipping in the air
but you didn't like that solution for
some reason
ah right right uh like leslie kelling
likes to talk about background utility
right somehow there's some
some notion of um yes i want if you just
tell the robot i want the
addition the in the you know i want that
let's sync clear let's say
then like you somehow there's something
implicit about don't break the dishes
don't
throw a dish at grandma or whatever you
know
i don't know but there's something else
that you have to write down if you
really don't want
crazy things to happen um
but i don't know i don't know if
multi-objective is the the right way i
think there's probably
um bigger architecture questions about
layered control
my thinking has taken me more towards
sort of how do you compose
um multiple controllers into a full
architecture
and then maybe the architecture would
protect you you would have lower level
controllers that would never throw
something
out of the sink and then you know maybe
you you specialize
so not to say that i'm against a
multi-objective formulation that's just
not where my
head has been sure no it's just
it's fair um okay
um maybe one last question because we
before we let people go uh in europe
it's getting super late
uh the question is uh it's from cheering
fang
uh i see that the dance descriptors that
rust talked
about is also trained from neural
network that captures the correspondence
and probably people would do control rl
on top of those
representations how do you compare such
approaches to just run
neural networks end to end uh what are
the benefits
yeah yeah so um okay most of the people
who
talk about pixels to torques kind of
control
most of them have a big perception
network first that goes into a smaller
control policy network and they tend to
pre-train even if you're going to do
end-to-end training at the end
that you know the the perception need is
on this big network that tends to be
needed to be pre-trained whether it's
from
imagenet or whatever um so so for us
it's in that space and instead of
training and and
we one of the things that's really good
about the dense descriptors is that they
can
be trained on your robot on your data
self-supervised so
it basically the robot can just wave its
camera around or move some objects
around in front of it
and it comes up with this rich
perceptual representation with
very little human effort and it gives us
that
pre-trained perception network which we
then hand to whatever controller we want
whether it's a
robot whisperer one whether it's an
optimization based model-based
optimization one or whether it's a
an end-to-end trained deep one so
you know i feel that it's more
interpretable than arbitrary latent
representations that could come out of
our perception that we're trained out of
an auto encoder or whatever there's
other reasons why we kind of like it
but um certainly the self supervision is
pretty
pretty convenient
okay good um so that is
um that is a discord server
i don't know uh whether you're
interested in in joining
i'm happy to share the link to you so
that's where
all the participants are hanging out uh
and uh i'm pretty sure that there are
some some people who would be interested
in you know like trying
poking a little bit more um there are
also uh like maybe we can refine
uh the uh the problem
descriptions to arrive at something
tangible
and then that could also happen there so
i said
like it would be really great if if you
uh we're open to
uh just being in the server for a while
um
okay all right
yeah i i send you an email i see that
you say that like you're not checking
your emails so but i'm going to send you
an email it's
like i can remember the emails i have
the capability that's that single email
uh i'm promised it's going to be short
um
okay uh it was great having you uh
and and thanks for everyone attending
the boot camp
uh watching online um
and hope you had a a great uh week
and and looking forward to the whole
semester
and further interactions with everyone
who was involved
thank you thank you for organizing it it
was a great week
yeah our pleasure